foreign
[Music]
I've been pulled through time between
the past and the present in the future
[Music]
everything is turning
that's right
[Music]
round around
and around we go
all right
again
foreign
what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic Wonder we have a new
trailer for Loki season two a little TV
spot trailer that actually gives us
quite a bit of new footage and there is
one scene in particular that I find
extremely interesting involving Victor
timely AKA a variant of Kang the
Conqueror and this TV spot is really
focused on the fact that Loki is time
slipping he is going to the Past he is
going to the Future and he's kind of
just stuck in a Time Loop almost it
seems we hear him say again a couple of
times in this trailer implying that he's
done a few of these things that we see
him doing in the trailer a few times
already now there's a lot of things to
break down including Jonathan Majors
there is a lot of footage of him in this
trailer as king the Conqueror which is a
good sign for him remaining Kang and he
who remains in Victor timely in all the
variants of King in the MCU in fact his
trial is actually set for September 6th
that's just a couple of days away but
we'll break down everything you need to
know about this TV spot in this video
and if you're new be sure to subscribe
to the channel so you don't miss out on
any of the latest MCU news and if you
subscribe to the channel and leave a
comment on our videos you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner gets to pick one item
and we pick a winner at the end of each
month so like I said to start off with
there is a ton of footage of Victor
timely Jonathan Majors as Victor timely
specifically and this is great news
because before Marvel Studios was
avoiding really showing or talking about
Jonathan Majors or Kang at all if you
weren't aware several months ago
Jonathan Majors was arrested and he was
charged with several cases of assault
however Jonathan Majors from the very
beginning was stating that he was
innocent and was in fact the victim and
he has presented a lot of evidence that
support this however the trial is still
going on right now like I said it picks
up again in a couple of days and the
outcome of the trial will ultimately
determine whether or not Jonathan Majors
state days in the MCU as king the
Conqueror or if Marvel Studios decides
to recast Kang the Conqueror and replace
Jonathan Majors we've done a lot of
videos covering Jonathan majors in his
case if you want to check those out you
can but the main point to take away from
this trailer is the fact that Marvel
Studios really wasn't even mentioning
let alone showing Jonathan Majors as
Kang or Victor timely before but now
they are and they're showing him a lot
which is a good sign a good sign that
he'll remain King the Conqueror in the
MCU but like I said the trial is only in
a couple of days we'll see what happens
there but it's looking good right now
now the trailer starts off with Loki
saying now what I'm about to tell you is
going to be hard to believe again
meaning he has already done this he's
already had this conversation and we're
assuming that it's with Owen Wilson's
Mobius the end of Loki season 1 showed
Loki and Sylvie killing king the
Conqueror well really just Sylvie
killing king to conquer or he who
remains a variant of gang and Loki gets
sent back to the TVA however when Loki
finds Mobius and Hunter B15 they have no
idea who he is now we've kind of figured
this out it does seem like they have no
idea because the TVA has essentially
been reset plus Loki has gone back in
time so Mobius has zero idea about
anything that happened with Loki season
1. so Loki has to tell him everything
and convince him and show him proof that
the timekeepers aren't real that it's
actually he who remains King the
Conqueror running the TV8 and that they
weren't created by the TVA all the
people that worked there including
Mobius and Hunter B15 but they were
actually taken from timelines and it
sounds like he has to convince him over
and over again because of the time
sloping however it does look like this
is working to Loki's advantage in a
weird type of way the second scene that
we see in the trailer is him saying I've
been pulled throughout time from the
past present and the future and when he
says this we see a lot we see him in
front of piranha Power Sports and which
we believe we could possibly see Mobius
in the background either buying or
selling a jet ski we've talked about
this before but he could be time
glitching to a point in time in a
timeline where Mobius was still an
actual person with a real if not a TVA
employee and we know that Mobius loved
jet skis even though he said and thinks
he's never ridden one before but he also
didn't know that he had a normal life
before so this very well could be him in
the background and we really hope it is
him we can see a male in the far back
who has blonde hair looks like it could
be him we also see him go to the world's
Colombian Exposition which was set in
1893 in Chicago and this was set to
celebrate the 400th anniversary of
Christopher Columbus arriving in the
Americas and the fair was set to
showcase the technological advancements
of America and the world and it included
the world's first ferris wheel this is
where they're going to run into Victor
timely he's going to be presenting some
of his technology at the world fair we
also see Rafael casal's character we
don't know his actual name yet but we do
know that he is a former TVA agent named
X5 but we do know that he's been using
temporal chaos to become a famous movie
star in the 1970s in Hollywood and we do
know that Loki is going to track him
down probably because he knows something
because there's no way he can just
Escape keep the TVA and go to a timeline
without knowing a little inside
information so I'm assuming they're
gonna track him down because they need
to know what he knows now from here
there are a few really important scenes
that we need to talk about in this
trailer and in the trailer before we see
these sacred timeline and we see a
bridge going out to that timeline we've
even seen Mobius get in a sort of
spacesuit and go out to it and in this
trailer we see that again however we see
something a little bit different this
time we see King the Conqueror designing
it and I believe he is designing it with
kihoi Kwan's character OB now what we
know about OB is that he is responsible
for creating a lot of the tva's
technology we see OB looking through
some sort of a tunnel which seems to be
kind of a scale replica a model design
of what they are about to build which
could be the sacred timeline we also see
Kang looking at somebody demonstrating
how to go out to the timeline in a
spacesuit and kind of create and
manipulate it I believe believe that
this is him working with kihoi Kwan his
character Obi way back when they first
invented the TVA and King the Conqueror
was still figuring out how to write the
sacred timeline because we did learn in
the first season of Loki that the future
was still being written it was being
written by the supposed time Keepers but
of course we would go on to find out
that it was he who remains and he who
remains would be the one that would
write the ending or the future of the
Sacred timeline and it was constantly
being written I believe that's what we
are seeing here we see kind of two parts
of the timeline here one part that is
very organized and put together and then
what looks to be the end that is a bunch
of different timelines that need to be
put into one sacred timeline so we
believe that this is the end or as far
as time has been written so far so you
can't go further into the future than
that part right there that's as far as
anybody has ever gone in that timeline
at least so Loki is time slipping to the
past and the present and the future but
that might be as far as he can go to
that point in time which is why in
another scene we see him under B15 OB
Mobius Etc looking at the sacred
timeline knowing that they have to do
something here something to stop King
the Conqueror which of course I'm sure
will be revealed hopefully relatively
soon there are a couple of other Big
scenes we have to talk about but first
big thank you to our friends over at
comic book direct for sponsoring this
video
if created a website and company that
makes comic book shopping the easiest it
can possibly be they deliver Comics
straight to your door you can get
one-off Comics or you can sign up for an
entire run and get a pretty big discount
if you do so and they'll ship the latest
issue right to your door each week they
have the latest from Marvel if you're
trying to keep up to date with all the
recent projects they have the latest
from DC as well and it's an all-in-one
shop for your Comics everything that you
need in one place you can sign up for a
membership to get free shipping and a
mystery box each month and the next 100
people to sign up get 20 off their first
order using the link in the description
down below
another big scene is with Hunter B15
trying to access her temp Pad but miss
minutes says no she says access denied
keep in mind that Hunter B15 was shown
that she had a life in a timeline on
Earth towards the end of Loki season 1
however when Loki goes back to the TBA
she doesn't know any of that so he has
to reveal that to her again as he says
and no doubt he does he convinces Mobius
he convinces her they're all on the same
team again all with kind of different
assignments and it looks like she is
trying to track down some information
about Kang or go somewhere but miss
minutes says no because Miss minutes of
course works for Kang and of course is
going to report back to him another
pretty crazy scene is with Mobius and
the first trailer that we got we know
that Mobius is going to go in a space
suit he's gonna go out to the timeline
and investigate it or try to do
something to it we briefly see that in
this TV spot as well but what we see
also is that his suit is apparently
falling apart it is literally
disintegrating and he is looking up in
shock and awe at something now I don't
think he's gonna die I think he's gonna
survive the series hopefully but
whatever is happening to him at this
point in time it looks like it's very
serious and it looks like he's in
trouble there is also the possibility
that he does die but Loki simply goes to
the past and says okay let's do it again
that is the one benefit that Loki could
have from time slipping and perhaps he
even maybe gets control over slipping
back and forth through time so when he
messes up something he could simply time
slip back in fact based off of a leak
that we've heard kihoi Kwan's character
OB gives him a device that allows him to
control his time slipping so I'm betting
that's what we are seeing here Loki
trying to do something multiple times
failing multiple times going back in
time doing it again so there is a
possibility that we could see some
characters die but then Loki simply goes
back in time and kind of erases it
another really important scene is a
scene with Loki and Sibley where they
grab each other's hands and apparently
combine their powers to make them
stronger which is really cool to to see
in a really interesting idea remember
they are both Loki both variants of each
other and perhaps they are stronger
together perhaps when variants come
together and combine their powers they
are actually stronger we don't really
know the rules of the Multiverse and the
MCU right now they're not defined yet
but it does look like Loki and Sylvia
are using their powers together to make
them stronger here which is really
interesting and we could see this happen
a lot in the MCU moving forward if
variants do come together hopefully we
see this in Avengers Secret Wars at
least then we have another scene where
Victor timely seems to be holding
something up inspecting it and what it
looks to be is his time chair Victor
timely in the comics is kind of a
displaced King he gets defeated by The
Fantastic Four finds himself time
displaced where he runs into Doctor Doom
and he decides to go back in time and
disguise himself as Victor timely and
from there he basically creates an
Empire but that's the comics we know
that Marvel Studios and the MCU don't
always do what the comics do in fact
they don't do it a lot so this could be
a king who is first learning to time
travel and it looks like he is designing
his time chair that takes him through
time through the Multiverse for the
first time here and that seems to be
what he's inspecting he just designed it
and now he is looking at it if you take
a look at the top of this object that he
is holding it does look a lot like the
time chair that we saw and Ant-Man and
the wasp quantumania and then in the
last really important scene of this new
TV spot is we see Loki actually going
out on this bridge that we've seen
several times now to the timeline
without a suit Mobius had a suit but do
keep in mind Loki is a God he can
survive in space we have seen that so
he's not a human like Mobius Mobius
needs a spacesuit because he can't
breathe in space now the TVA is supposed
to exist outside of space and time
however we still aren't exactly sure how
everything works here and it looks like
there probably isn't oxygen right
outside of the Sacred timeline and we
don't know if some place outside of
space and time has oxygen either which
is why Mobius a human needs a spacesuit
but like I mentioned it looks like Loki
and the team might fail a little bit a
few times at least and Loki just has to
go back in time and like he says do it
again and in this scene and the final
scene we see our full team here we have
Loki Mobius Sylvie OB Hunter B15 and
Casey who he met in Loki season 1. and
that's it for our new TV spot Loki
season 2 truly does look amazing but let
us know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below please don't forget
to like the video and subscribe to stay
up to date on all things relating to the
MCU and of course you can follow us on
Instagram and Twitter as well as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof
foreign